Well,
actually that day,
everything,
fairly verizon in my life,
I don't know what I don't know about
anyone else's life,
but in my life,
everything for a reason and even bad
things as far as reason that who knows,
it might turn out for be something else.
Um,
but
you know,
I don't fight creativity.
I don't fight against not being
creative.
If I'm not being creative and not
forcing it,
I just,
that's it.
I'm chilling.
You know what I'm saying?
What inspire me.
Yeah.
I want to say it's God.
Yeah,
Gia.
But I want to put it a different,
we,
we say it's the universe.
You know,
it's this thing that we don't know what
it's called.
Some people call it garden.
People have different names for it.
I don't know why they call it whatever
you want to call it.
I don't know.
Sometime I just said the universe,
that's what I call it at times.
And that's what inspires me.
You know,
the universe.
So that's,
it did,
I mean my kids,
um,
as I said before,
bucking the D is Amir.
But every now and again there is some
social thing that was Pakistan.
I song about justice,
our Asana board,
human rights are every know and again,
there's something happening in the world
where,
uh,
all right,
that's sung inspired by what's
happening.
But a lot of times,
no,
I'm writing songs
that,
that has to do with it all I'd have to
do with
establishing um,
oh,
ah,
reestablishing our connection to the
universe.
I was,
oh,
uh,
spirituality,
you know,
re reconnecting our consciousness to
universities that has nothing to do with
physical things are social things are
political things.
It's all to do with spiritual things.
And that's where I find that's where I
love to write songs,
the Moss in that place,
not in the political social thing.
I like to write songs in that spiritual
please.
That's,
that's what that given the best feeling.
You know,
this advice I ever receive.
There's has been a few,
but I must say today,
the best advice I ever received is one
that
I would say I received from myself
because it's based upon my experiences
and the best advice I received from Maya
said,
if is follow your intuition,
follow your mind.
Cause mean many times I have not,
and I've seen where I should have.
So I,
and you know each individual to each his
own.
It's not sometimes,
not everybody's intuition is,
is an thing.
But where I am today in my life,
my intuition,
I should follow it.
And that is,
that is the advice I get from that inner
voice inside of me.
You know,
that speaks,
there's a voice inside them that speaks
the truth.
And I must always listen to that device.
If I did,
I wouldn't get money.
You wouldn't be in general.
Right?
That's the lesson.
That's the lesson zig and listened to
that.
That's,
that's the lesson.
That's what I'm talking about.
I learned something,
you know.